auf die straße gehen aber dafür
vielleicht getötet werden dafür stehen
jetzt die menschen in kasachstan dort wo
sich die lage immer weiter zuspitzt und
jetzt einen ganz dramatische neuen
höhepunkt erreicht der kasachische
präsident tokarev der teil der polizei
bei den protesten in kasachstan hier
sehen wir bilder davon aus genannt die
den schießbefehl und sie hören es auch
er kündigte an dass die von ihm so
bezeichneten anti terror einsätze bis
zur zitat kompletten auslöschung der
kämpfe andauern sollen es wird mit aller
härte durchgegriffen gegners verfolgt
das ich werd gegen die autoritäre
führung von korea das ist ein neuer
krisenherd nicht weit weg von uns und
ganz nahe bei bild live denn unser paul
ronzheimer ist genau dort ist auf dem
weg nach kasachstan auch dort in das
krisengebiet paul sagt uns ein bisschen
über diese angespannte lage du hast die
proteste in der ukraine miterlebt weist
wie blutig die dort niedergeschlagen
worden du warst in weißrussland hast
genau eine vergleichbare lage dort
erlebt und jetzt kasachstan
ich stehe jetzt in diesem moment in
kirgisistan dem nachbarland bei bishkek
das ist die stadt ganz nah an der grenze
wir haben heute morgen versucht dort
rüber zu kommen direkt rein nach
kasachstan und die katalanischen die
grenzbeamten die haben uns
zurückgedrängt und das hat natürlich
einen grund denn man will nicht dass der
westen hinschaut ist der besten sieht
das medien sehen was in diesem land
momentan passiert wir haben das internet
dort zum großen teil abgeschaltet die
menschen können sich nicht verbinden sie
können nicht miteinander telefonieren
was wir aber hören und beobachten und
auch mit kontakten mit dem wir dennoch
in kontakt stehen könnt das ist
dramatisch ist insbesondere in almaty
der millionenstadt dass es dort angriffe
gibt der regierungstruppen mit hilfe von
russischen soldaten mit hilfe auch von
armenischen und weißrussischen soldaten
denn die wurden zur hilfe gezogen weil
man die menschen nieder schießen will
die gegen das regime demonstrieren
wenn man es einmal zurück zum ursprung
dieser unruhen es ging um treibstoff
jetzt geht s war und so so viel mehr
es fing an zwischen den tagen es ging
tatsächlich um diese treibstoff um
erdgas das sich verdoppelt hatte im
falls betriebsjahr und da sind die
menschen im westen des landes dieses
riesigen landes kasachstan fast achtmal
so groß wie deutschland auf die straße
gegangen und dann hat sich das weiter
verlagert eben im nach almaty in dieser
millionenstadt und dort ist es eskaliert
wir haben dort in der vergangenen nacht
von schüssen gehört auch jetzt geht es
weiter der präsident habe den
schießbefehl erteilt hat gesagt die
polizei soll schießen auf diejenigen die
dort demonstrieren die durch
protestieren und bis dann gibt es nur
sehr sehr wenige unabhängige beobachter
ich hab grad darüber berichtet dass wir
nicht durchgelassen worden sind hier an
der grenze dass man auch über die
landgrenze uns nicht reinlassen wollte
andere flughäfen sind geschlossen und so
ist die menschheit sind die menschen
darauf angewiesen auf die wenigen
beobachter die momentan in dieser stadt
wer sind diese mutigen menschen die da
im moment trotz dieser polizeigewalt
dieses schießbefehls auf die straße
gehen und welche rolle spielt da hinter
der mann den wir da nicht sehen putin
das sind wahnsinnig mutige menschen kein
das sind diejenigen die in den
vergangenen jahren schon genug hatten
von dieser autokratie von dem regime von
denjenigen die nicht abgegeben haben von
dem reichtum man muss auch sagen der
westen hat auch eine verantwortung es
gab große lobbyisten aus deutschland
auch politiker die diesen regime am ende
geholfen haben aus europa putin spielt
jetzt die entscheidende rolle denn er
wurde vom präsidenten sozusagen zu hilfe
gerufen weil er mit den eigenen truppen
es nicht geschafft hat das kreuz in
schach zu halten und jetzt will man mit
der hilfe von wladimir putin mit der
hilfe von russischen truppen dafür
sorgen dass diejenigen die protestierer
geschossen werden und das ist wieder
eine eroberung sozusagen des regimes im
ganzen land gibt paul ronzheimer
berichtet von den unruhen in kasachstan
der präsident hat schießbefehl erteilt
für die menschen die dort auf die straße
gehen paul ronzheimer vielen herzlichen
dank